nous verrons un marionnettiste une de ces lignes
les marionnettistes de la République tchèque aujourd'hui sont déjà la République tchèque
gérer notre siège social commun où
pardonne-moi, ces agneaux sont assis, rien
comprendre ce qu'ils veulent d'eux, ils ne font rien
comprendre qu'ils continuent d'appuyer sur eux
continuer à leur demander de se retirer
les gens dans la rue citent et dirigent
négociations avec les autorités sur le volontariat
abandon du pouvoir, c'est-à-dire
Loukachenko en tête de la verticale
pouvoir à la tête de l'Etat volontairement
avec 80 pour cent des voix doit passer
im power est à partir de là, allez commandes
doit donner doit aux nôtres locaux ces ils
indigné devant l'étang à l'intérieur dit un
c'est impossible en biélorussie la situation n'est pas la même
négocier, je ne parle pas de la Pologne
Je dis là ils commencent à tirer les ficelles je
Je ne parle pas de l'Ukraine, mais nous avons conduit à partir de là
ce n'est pas la politique du gouvernement
mais il y a assez de ces Maydanuts dont
J'ai parlé, y compris malheureusement de
Russie un certain afflux de personnes qui
bien qu'ils ne grimpent pas sur nos baïonnettes d'anime
ils ont laissé les garçons, on a vu qui aujourd'hui
erré là-bas la nuit et essayé
provoquer la police